gta 6 could be headed back to single
player dlc and diablo 4 is promising it
won't be paid a win
known gta tipster tez 2 shared new
rumors in a post on gta forums in
response to a comment about the reports
of the world of gta 6 expanding over
time tez 2 said this means quote
rockstar will go back to how they were
planning future content before gta
online success boomed so in other words
rockstar was allegedly working on
single-player dlc for gta 5 but
cancelled those plans to focus on gta
online depressing for gta 6 test 2
claimed that new cities and missions
will come to the game as dlc and they
will definitely be planned out before 6
releases the tipster also said they
believe the new content for gta 6 will
take the form of instant new cities or
islands similar to north yankton from
gta 5. tez 2's reasoning is because that
way rockstar can introduce new heist for
the next gta online mode with each new
dlc i want single player dlc so bad that
tez if you're right i might name my
first child after you keyword might
don't hold me to that
very little is known about gta 6 but
rumor has it that the game will take
place in vice city and feature two lead
characters one of whom is a latina woman
because of the lack of solid information
fans are pretty hungry for any small
details that they can find
so hungry that they've apparently been
dialing a number in gta online looking
for those details in a since deleted
tweet test 2 urged online players to
dial 505
505-555-0175 in game for the first hint
of gta 6. unfortunately as pointed out
by twitter user not a phase mom the
number simply leads to hold music which
ironically fits the situation we're all
in on hold waiting for a trailer to drop
or just a big blog post full of
information
but speaking of blog posts with
information let's talk about diablo 4
because blizzard has released a bunch of
information about their post launch
plans for the game diablo 4 seasons are
modeled after those in diablo 3 and will
regularly introduce new content and
gameplay features to keep the experience
fresh game director joe shelley states
in the blog that the game's first season
will begin shortly after launch with the
team aiming to bring up to four seasons
a year to diablo 4 with each new season
including major new features quest lines
enemies legendary items and more going
hand in hand with diablo 4 seasons is
the game's seasonal battle pass given
the reaction to the free to play diablo
immortal which also offers a seasonal
battle pass that rewards various pieces
of gear gems and crafting materials for
spending money some fans of the
franchise have been concerned that a
similar system could appear in diablo 4.
blizzard makes clear in this quarterly
update that won't be the case
emphasizing multiple times that there
will be no way to pay for power in
diablo 4. according to keegan clark
director of product for diablo 4 diablo
4 will offer various cosmetics through
an in-game shop and a season pass that
will allow both free and paid reward
tracks with a goal of adding quote value
to players experience of the game but ok
now i need you to get creative in the
comments i want you to come up with in a
couple of lines
the story to the gta 6 single player dlc
you know you never know i might know
somebody over at rock star i might be
able to get that story slid in there and
meet i don't but i'm you know you never
know so
get creative with it
later